well thank you Randy and thank you to
all of you who are here and this it's so
exciting for me to be here let alone to
be celebrating my 30th Stanford reunion
with so many people in my class that I
see out there and I still recognize
still can see still recognize but I got
to tell you I would have never predicted
than 30 years ago when I was sitting out
there that I would ever be standing up
here that if I and even if was standing
up here clearly the topic would not be
aging um I could have never predicted
that um I would have been uh I speak for
Myra strober work family balance classes
on Elder Care uh that I would speak to
Stanford faculty and staff on the
Medicare prescription drug program or
that I would have written an article for
Stanford Business Magazine on a subject
that's become very near and dear to my
heart which is creating moments of joy
in the elder care experience but
probably most of all I would have never
predicted that I would have felt that my
greatest accomplishment was my role as
caregiver to my mother for the last 10
years of her life so that was that's the
Elder Care side but today we're going to
wear the gerontologist hat and we're
going to talk be talking about
successful aging and I want to make you
just as successful in this next phase of
life as you have been up to this point
so far so that's my goal I want you to
be successful ful in the next phase of
life but I will tell you success is a
very different playing field from how
you defined success before and I can
tell you there is no correlation between
success in business and success in aging
no correlation there um but you are one
up because there is a correlation with
education so the education that we did
get 30 whatever many years ago here at
Stanford is going to is going to put you
one up in terms of successful aging so
some of the things I'm going to talk
about today you would have heard some of
them are common knowledge to you some of
them are going to be new some of them
may be a challenge to accept for you I'm
going to be bringing some of the um
there's a lot of thought leaders in the
field of aging and very supportive
positive positive aging um resources
here at Stanford that I'm going to bring
into my presentation and then I'm
actually going to show you some role
models of aging from my family and
friends so you're going to see me with
different haircuts different weights as
of this morning somebody said oh a
different hair color Esther so maybe
even different hair colors today um but
these are the role models in my family
but I am sure that there are Role Models
amongst your family and friends so I
really want you to think about those
people what is it and I think you're
going to see some themes here that these
people have um uh taken on in their life
and I want to remind you to remember
those people you know I have a seven
minute memory I'm lucky if I can
remember something within seven minutes
of hearing it so you're probably not
going to remember everything I've said
but I want you those role models to be
reminders to you going forward so why
don't we why don't we start here um
successful aging I bet you think I came
up because this is a business school
group successful aging actually
successful aging is indeed a
gerontological term and the American
gerontological society defines
successful aging as not just to add life
as to add Years to Life but to put life
into those years so I know if you went
into a bookstore not that they have an
aging section but you know you'd see
books on diet and fitness that's the
putting the years into the
life that's the health um uh physical
and mental health but to put the life
into years that's the emotional
well-being you know Mind Body that's the
soul and I love the word Joy so to me
it's having a joy-filled life whatever
you whatever words might fit with you
but it's the emotional well-being that's
that's really that's really the key um
and so as we push this envelope of a
lifetime it is less so in our genes or
in the stars but it's really all about
the choices we make and lifestyle
choices play a far greater role in
successful aging than genetics wealth or
race so two top lines it's emotional
well-being and it's lifestyle
choices so um now for some of
you well let's get right into it there's
a
few there's a few barriers to successful
aging denial and dysfunctional
families you know if denial was a disase
disease the results would be
fatal I don't know what it is about
human nature but there's this gap
between knowing and doing and you know
what you resist does indeed persist and
what you want to do is you want to
narrow that Gap and you want to step you
want to step forward because frequently
The Angst associated with denial is far
greater than the discomfort that might
come from acceptance and moving on and
then Al although people may think that
acknowledging aging is giving into it I
would say just the opposite not
acknowledging aging is giving into it
because you lose options and those
There's an opportunity cost to those
options it's an opportunity cost in
terms of your emotional well-being your
health and there's can be a financial
cost to it too so what's the breakout
strategy the breakout strategy is
courage and I got to tell you it's going
to be take less courage to acknowledge
aging think plan and act than it is for
this gentleman who looks like he's about
70 years old I don't really want to try
rock climbing so there really isn't as
much courage to getting past this denial
Gap but there is this denial Gap and I
would say that um you're only hurting
yourself it's kind of
self-preservation so my point to you
would be if not now
when so that's denial let's talk about
the next barrier
the next barrier is family one of the
first things that I learned in
gerontology school is that aging is all
about
family childhood is all about family
later adulthood is all about families
and families today certainly seem
dysfunctional now maybe this is for most
of Mo for most of my class here this was
you know the norm Aussie and Harriet
Circa
1950s okay so maybe it was romanticized
a little for for TV but what's the
reality TV to show show today aie
Osborne I mean what kind of a family is
that you know
so
so um Family Ties are less strong um
there's a me generation who's replaced a
nuclear family uh there's parent issues
sibling issues uh divorce is higher and
although people although the the fact
that people live in different places may
not be dysfunctional but families that
used to be in the same Community operate
more functionally so family ties are
less strong and certainly respect for
elders has declined in this culture not
necessarily in other cultures but
certainly in this culture so what you
have is that the primary support
structure for aging the family is
broken so what's the breakout strategy
here you know it's forgiveness I see it
time and again there needs to be more
forgiveness in this world um first of
all forgive yourself for whatever you
did or didn't do in your life with your
family and friends and then you got to
forgive others you know forgive your
parents for not being the parents that
you would wish they had been forgive
your children for not being the children
you had wished them to become and
forgive your siblings for whatever
happened in the sandbox
but forgiveness you know it really gives
you back the present and the future
because when you when when you're when
you have a grie grievance and you're
dealing in the past you bring it into
the present and those present days were
once your future days so really
forgiveness brings you peace and it
brings you back the present and the
future and here I'd like to talk a
little about some of the work of Dr Fred
lusin who's the founder and director of
the Stanford forgiveness project he's
known as an expert in um the healing
power of forgiveness he has a framework
for forgiveness training if this is
something that you need to work on his
book forgive for good is a wonderful
model of this he also happens to be in
the middle of a um online course of
forgiveness training he really did some
powerful work with Catholic and
Protestant families in Northern Ireland
and um the research shows forgiveness
positively affects relationships leads
to to less stress people who are more
forgiving forget for report fewer health
problems and people who blame others for
their problems have higher incidences of
illnesses such as cardiovascular disease
and Cancers so learning to forgive is
not only good for your emotional
well-being it's also good for your
physical and mental
health and I'll tell you only
forgiveness can produce a life Without
Regrets and it's not what you do in life
that usually is the regrets it's what
you didn't do so I really encourage you
to not wait to the aha
moment of what's important of don't wait
to that aha moment at end of life on
your deathbed as to what's important in
life you really want to learn it now
apply it to your life and and that's
really a lesson that I learned in with
my mother um we got to a point of
forgiveness I never expect anything in
return and I got I got the world and it
does
work and and you know there's some other
resources for this Mitch album and his
works on um Tuesdays with myy talks
about what's really important in life um
just one more day The Five People You
You Meet in Heaven that's what you want
to learn now and apply it to your
life so let's let's let's move on let's
go to um for some audiences I say
they're the seven secrets of successful
aging for this audience it's the seven
strategies for successful
aging okay so social networks are the
elixir of life we are social
animals and the most important
relationship is indeed your spousal
relationship that is the most important
one you hear of situations where um uh
one spouse dies and the other spouse
dies very frequently after the that that
first spouse so it's that spousal
relationship that's the most that is
indeed the most important relationship
but it can't be the only relationship
you really need to get out and make
other friends particularly when you move
out of the workforce and if you're and
I'm talking about friends not
acquaintances so if your if your um
group of friends are really
acquaintances from the workforce that's
not what's going to sustain you when
you're out of the the workforce so you
really have to make other friends and
you need to make younger friends too um
Family by choice also counts it's
important because families have there's
a lot of divorce and uh families are
smaller family by choice counts and and
actually sometimes the research shows
that actually family by choice counts
better than family relationships because
of those dis dysfunctional families that
I talked about so family by choice also
counts um and this is what my Mo my
mother would say this was my
grandmother's saying that my mother took
on to have a friend you have to be a
friend so again I am not talking about
uh acquaintances I am talking about
being present in a
relationship
uh and it's it's opening your heart and
taking people in this is the love
factor and um two comments I wanted to
make for I'm actually an example of that
um a woman who is divorced course not
married I'm also no children also happen
to be an only child so there are
probably other women that went into
business that that have that profile you
really have to think about what is your
social support structure for when you're
older and you you really need to think
think seriously about that and then the
other comment I would make for for some
of the men in the audience that
typically it's the woman that is the
nurturer of relationships so if you are
one of those people who might end up
divorced or your spouse dies you need to
think about how are you you need to
nurture those relationships in your life
too so here's um here's Lorraine
Lorraine happened to be my client at
Price waterhous this is a picture of
Lorraine uh this was on her retirement
party
invitation um she was retiring at 80 so
this is probably when she was 79 after
she came back from uh from Hawaii
now Lorraine's Lorraine's um she has
this is her family she has four children
11 grandchildren and I think five and
Counting great grandchildren everybody
in this family wants to be with Lorraine
everybody and she even does bookkeeping
work for her one of her sons um she's in
the jazz club and she's in two
sororities and she's doing yoga and
she's just totally totally involved and
even one of the cute Stories the two two
fellows two of her grandsons the older
one in the front older ones in the front
row they both had girlfriends that were
in her sorority so she just loved the
idea that she would they were all
sorority sisters one time I called her
on the phone it was a Wednesday night
and one 16-year-old from one son and a
uh eight-year-old from uh her daughter
were over at Grandma's having Sloppy
Joe's during their during their homew
doing their homework so this is the
family structure they all live in the
same area in San Diego this might have
been more what you would have seen in
another generation but still very much
intact um so the next one is uh my
friend Martha um Martha is in her 50s
but I know that Mar Martha is going to
successfully age because of the family
she has a family but she really believes
in family by choice and what she says is
a loving family is but an earlier heaven
and um there are some people in I've
this is from uh Christmas there I am in
the back there with my little hat with
her father and um well let's talk about
the saying you are an she had her 50th
birthday and so she invited her her
closest group of friends 175 people came
to her 50th birthday party and these
were really friends this is not
acquaintances these are friends but I'll
tell you a story I gave an 80th birthday
party party for my mother I told her she
could invite all of her friends she had
a list of 175 people at 80 years old so
you and for her 50th birthday party
somebody put a collage of pictures
together and here's what I love this you
are an awesome person and we consider it
a privilege to call you our friend so
Christmas dinner this is an example of a
family by choice Christmas dinner um one
one gentleman here her father went to
Stanford and got his master's at
Stanford and one thanks one Christmas
brought home one of his classmates that
classmate has been having Christmas
dinner with them over 50 years now um
and then another one of her husbands a
classmate from college their family has
been having Christmas dinner with them
for 25 years and their son Jason in the
back there everybody was giving toast so
Jason I think he was like 10 or 10 or
something he got up and he gave a toast
to family by choice those were the words
he used used I mean it was incredible so
even at the age of 10 he got the
importance of family by
choice okay now here's a different
different situation this is Doris um
Doris lived in the Skilled Nursing
Facility where my mother was and when I
first met Doris she said I love all
animals and some
humans she had pictures of cats and dogs
and everything had little socks with
dogs on them um but she was Charming now
here's someone else who um Doris retired
at 80 she had to start work at 50 her
husband became ill worked for 30 years
was an assistant um at carmont high
school worked for 30 years retired at 80
um was in skiled N but she had just a
wonderful outgoing personality had no
family but she developed this Core group
of people that I when I would see my
mother then I'd always go down to see
Doris afterwards I was not the only
person who did that and other people
after their loved one passed away still
came back to the Skilled Nursing
Facility just to see Doris so I gave you
three example more of a traditional
family more of family by choice or
someone who was alone who made who who
who established a a a friendship in a in
a different type of
environment so number two take all those
lemons and make lots of lemonade
that's what people who have successfully
done who successfully aged done they
make lots of lemonade this is that
seeing the extraordinary in the ordinary
or its mature defenses or its resilience
um uh what's the worst that can happen
to me because when you see the big
picture the glass really is half full
maybe it's full and it could be
overflowing and here I'd like to talk to
you a little about the work of the the
Stanford center on longevity and you
heard uh if you went next door you heard
Dr Tom Rando speak on some of the um
work they're doing on stem cell that
kind of the science but they also do a
lot of research and Dr Laura Carstensen
is the founder and director of the SE of
the center and she's out there to debunk
the misery myth here because the
research shows that people over 65
aren't as you know depressed as
everybody seems to think as a matter of
fact the people that the most depressed
are the 20-some and when you think back
on
it things are probably a lot easier for
you now than they were in the 20s so
it's the socio emotional selectivity
Theory and it makes sense that as your
time Horizon shortens and you see the
end you change what has value to you and
you are more interested in emotional
emotionally
related um activities and relationships
so and and also and emotionally
emotional goals and you're actually your
emotional skills improve you're less
self-centered you kind of go up maso's
hierarchy of needs and um you know for
me the bend there done that really makes
sense you know you've been there you've
done that and there's a lot of things
that you're not going to waste your time
on or energy or so it's it's a different
lifespan the the other thing is is um
the positivity effect that actually our
brains have a tendency when we're older
to think more you know to eliminate the
negative stimuli and we will think more
in the positive so so there's actually
re research that that supports this uh
Laura is the author has a new book out a
long bright future um where she um she
has an interesting section I'm not going
to share it with you I encourage you to
read the book on work hold she has
re-envisioned work across the across the
years um but her four four areas nourish
social relationships work longer save
more learn throughout your life and take
care of your body and the longevity
Center is committed to Bringing about
you know profound Improvement not just
focusing at end of life but really
Improvement quality of life for people
who are living longer across the across
the
lifespan um and here's some so here's
Marcel Marcela I called Marcela my
surrogate grandmother and Marcel H my
mother was a teacher Marcel happened to
be the principal at this one of the
schools that my mother taught at and
this is probably taken after Stanford
this is probably in the mid 80s we'd
always bring her out for brunch and um
Marcela I mean she she was born in
1900 and I Marcela died at 4 a in the
year 2000 in the Millennium and I know
that she just wanted to make to make it
to two centuries and I know that she had
a smile on her face when she got it
there but she was going to make it to
the year 2000 because she was born in
1900 um Irish Catholic went to church
every day um but the great best story I
have about Marcel is that I I took her
out for a dinner one time and I
purposely wanted to take her to a meat
market because I thought she'd get a
kick out of watching you know the pick
up the girls and everything so I took
her to a TGI Fridays in um she you know
hey come on these people they've got
life in them 85 years old yeah she
enjoyed going to the meat market so so
then when I get her there then you know
I'm really serious and I said well
Marcel I really brought you here because
I want to know your philosophy of Life
true story and not not necessarily that
she said it in this order but first she
said well I eat pretty well you know I
have steak and potatoes but of course
the steak back then probably wasn't all
marbled and it probably wasn't french
fries it was you know boiled potatoes um
and I have a drink every once in a while
and actually sometimes Marcel would ask
me she had a a a a young boy from the
neighborhood buy her groceries but
sometimes I'm the one who would buy her
liquor so she'd say would you get but
you need to get me the whiskey in the
plastic container because she couldn't
hold the LI the the glass one anymore so
I had to buy the liquor so she drinks a
little you not I like a little little
drink and then she said you know I don't
worry I really don't worry that much you
know I thought about it one day and I
thought what's the worst that can happen
to me and then I really thought about
the worst that could happen to me and I
thought you know what I can deal with
that and then I went on to think about
what's the probability that that worst
thing is going to happen to me and I
said you know it's probably never going
to be H it's never going to happen so
why will I waste today worrying about
tomorrow you know I gave you the
Forgiveness why take yesterdays and lose
today's here's somebody saying why worry
about tomorrow I lose my today's so
that's that's how she you know it's like
it's this it's it's seeing the world in
a different in different eyes the other
thing is they did a study on centurians
and when somebody people live to to be a
hundred you know they've lost a lot of
things in life there's an ability to
deal with loss so again there's this
resilienc
um mature defenses Because by the time
you've been a 100 you've lost family
you've lost friends you've lost physical
abilities mental abilities position in
the workforce position in the community
but it's this ability to deal with loss
you see the glass the glass is always
half full or
overflowing another one is my aunt gr at
this picture my aunt gr is probably
about 105 years old she died at
107 um Aunt gr I was told at her 100th
birthday was wearing high heels and
dancing out there and in this picture
she she did have difficulty walking so
she was in a wheelchair but ladies she
was wearing a cable knit threepiece B
beautiful burgundy you can tell from the
beautiful burgundy three-piece cable
knit pants suit with her pearl necklace
her pearl earrings her quaffed hair
quaffed lipstick and I swear to you I
remember her in black stockings and
Ferragamo pumps if they had Vogue for
and she had beautiful skin if they had V
Vogue for centurians my aunt gr should
have been on the cover but now Aunt gr
lived with a couple and Keith was the
the husband so Keith would pick up her
uh she was in Nova Scotia Keith would
pick up her um drugs at the pharmacy and
pharmacies there also have like a retail
portion so she would call the pharmacist
give give him her credit card and to
have a little Pur purchase that would go
in the bag and she said now Keith don't
look in the bag and of course Keith did
otherwise I couldn't tell you this story
and um it was Oil of Olay she has she
could have been the poster child for Oil
of Olay and I've had other clients who
have used Oil of Olay ladies I think we
got to go to Oil of Olay it really we
got some really longitudinal studies
here it really works so dancing at 100
and oil of olle at I'm sure
107 so Point number three live with
Integrity this is living by the golden
rule never forget to say thank you and
when in doubt
forgive and I'll tell you the best
example of well respect grat it's other
words respect gratitude and Grace
respect allows for
acceptance gratitude brings
happiness and forgiveness softens the
heart and the best example I can give of
that is uh is my mom um my
mother was she was amaz the two words
that she two words that she used most of
all were thank you she always said thank
you the next three and we were told
whether it was being in the hospital or
or whatever
Senior Living facility she was in that
we were some of the few people who did
did thank thank say thank you next three
words she used were I love you which
were the words that I got the benefit of
but I'll tell you that wasn't words we
used when I was growing up and how that
started was my goddaughter in her teens
when she'd leave me a message or
whenever she' talked to me she would say
I love you Esther I got that on my
message machine once I kept it and it
just made me feel so good so I started
saying that to my mother so this became
the words that we use so much in later
life life um One time my mother came to
me and it was after she had fractured a
hip and we were in she was in skilled
nursing I went to see her she starts
with well I had a talk with major Domo
today that was usually not my mother's
tone I had no idea what had happened and
major Domo was the executive director of
the Skilled Nursing Facility so well Mom
what what happened well I told him that
the residents don't have enough respect
for the AIDS not the AIDS don't have
enough respect for the residents the
residents don't have enough respect for
the AIDS that's how my mother thought
that's a point of being grateful even
when my mother got to uh closer to end
of life she was no longer she was
non-ambulatory she couldn't walk she
couldn't move in bed she had to be fed
she was happy and there was a smile on
her face and there was a twinkle in her
eye and I actually was at a
function um actually yesterday for at
Golden Gate University and it happened
that honoring a friend of mine is
alumnist of the year and it happened
that the head of the um the major Domo
of that Skilled Nursing Facility who's
in rotary with my friend was there and
she she even commented you know Esther
when your mom was there everybody loved
seeing your mom we always got her
dressed up but there was a joy I really
felt she lived as long as she did was
the joy that she brought into the world
and the joy she brought out in other
people so number four start and end each
day with a smile you know let's let's a
sense of humor goes a long way and I got
to tell you grandchildren go a long way
any kind of young children I am leaving
next uh Thursday to go my grandchildren
aged two girls three and seven are in
Boston and I go trick-or-treating with
them every year so I I'm the cool
Grandma who goes in costumes so this
year I have my my Cleopatra I'm kind of
Cleopatra outfit my black wig I always
have a wig and I have a king Tutt
headdress so anything anything with
grandchildren is is good um and don't
take yourself too seriously you know
really don't take yourself too seriously
particularly in the next phase and make
sure you have some fun I've we've talked
different whatever your definition of
fun is now this isn't fun to me but I
had to have something here for the men
in the audience this may absolute fun
for you so whatever it is make sure you
have some fun it's seeing the
extraordinary in the ordinary and I will
tell you the time value of Joy it only
takes a moment when you think about
those really important points in your
life they were moments so take time for
those moments of
Joy so here's Marcela again this is a
picture of U my former boyfriend some of
you might remember him
and Marcel and this is my Annie be and
we would always go we would generally go
out um usually to brunch and so we go
stop frequently stop on the marina go
green and go kite flying so here Marcel
looks a little older so maybe she's like
87 and I'm you know my aunt would have
been in her 80s and I just love this
picture you know this 807 whoa you know
I mean have fun another story to tell on
Marcel she also liked to go to this
restaurant senior PE
um that used to be uh where the
McCormick and ketos is now at the
giradelli
square it wasn't for the view it wasn't
actually for the food but it was for one
particular dish because she loved to
order this dish son of a
stew and so we would never give Marcela
Marcel what would you like son of a
stew she just loved that you
know
and uh one time we'd like to go to baloa
Cafe and we always had RIS fizzes and uh
one time the the waitress came around to
take our order and she no we'll have
another RIS and one time she was a
little tittering as we came out but you
know we had a we had a we had great fun
um okay diet and fitness number five
this is common sense this I got to tell
you this is common sense eat
nutritiously
exercise regularly eat nutritiously low
on sugars low on fats low on
salt um uh vegetables fruits vegetables
um uh whole food whole grains exercise
regularly um 150 minutes a week moderate
exercise preferably 30 minutes a day um
at least 5 days a week regularly
moderate aerobic exercise no vices no
smoking no drugs Al alcohol in
moderation alcohol in
moderation and I'll tell you subjective
subjective health is key this frequently
comes up subjective Health great example
was my mother she would say you know I'm
in good health I'm in good shape for the
shap how are you doing I'm in good shape
for the shape I'm in she had so many
things wrong with her but that's not her
perception perceived health is key
um so here's the I love this one of the
Mediterranean diet P pyramid and part of
the reason I really love it is if you
notice on the bottom the base is
exercise exercise is key so here I want
to share with you um some of the work of
Dr Jim freeze who is Professor of
immunology and Rheumatology over at
Stanford Medical Center really
considered kind of the granddaddy of
positive of positive aging at a time
when most literature focused on the
failure of success in aging he looked at
it a little differently and and felt
that you know if you could push out you
know you can you can only push out human
like like Tom mentioned you can only
push out human life so far but if you
can push the onset of a disability
you've compressed the period of illness
or disability so it's the compression of
morbidity Theory which with which Jim is
known for and which the research does
indeed pan out
um three primary prevention
techniques common
sense no smoking no obesity
exercise that alone and he's done
studies with Runners about our age
significantly pushed out the onset of of
of chronic disease and have found that
even with a people like Runners it
doesn't necessarily mean that they have
um more injuries um even though they're
doing the running than the than the rest
of the population some ger geriatricians
doctors you know some people will say in
our field that that the diseases of
Aging are really not of Aging per se but
they're of
disuse exercise is really a key element
to the key element to this let me tell
you what the Alzheimer's Association
says heart disease high blood pressure
diabetes stroke can increase your risk
of heart disease adopt a brain healthy
diet physical exercise because essential
for Ming maintaining good flow to the
brain as well as encouraging new brain
cells mental activity to keep you sharp
a low level of education does relate to
a higher risk of Alzheimer so this
Stanford education was good for you
social engagement social engagement
interaction maintains Bri vi brain
vitality and isol ol ation is related to
a higher risk of Alzheimer's Alzheimer's
dis uh Association would also say that
exercise is more protective against
alzheimer's than any of the drugs
Alzheimer's drugs currently available so
exercise is key uh the Stanford Health
Improvement um Stanford has a h Health
Improvement program it's p primarily
it's like their employee assistance
program it's it's generally for staff
and um families
and retirees however I spoke yesterday
with um Wes alleys who runs the hip
program because I said you know can
alumni go and he goes sure they can come
your group can come so if any of you are
in this area and take a look at the hip
programs on the um on their website that
you know say that you're an alumni you
came to this session and you can you can
actually take advantage of those um so
let's let's talk about okay okay so
here's Al and Napoleon Napoleon's in the
black Al's in the white I happen to
there's a bike bike ride along the bay
where I go I've seen Allan Napoleon for
years and so finally a couple years ago
when I was doing this bike ride I
decided to you know each time I go by
it's like this gerontologist in me needs
to say something so finally I stopped
and said you know I think this is great
I see you guys out here all the time so
I decided I'd add them to my speech so
um uh a couple of months ago I I stopped
them and asked if I could interview them
so interesting story with Alan Napoleon
is that they are they they met walking
in 1997 they've been walking together
three days a week since
1997 they um are both 78 years
old and when Al was in his late 40s he
he oh I asked well did you guys exercise
a lot when you were younger well
Napoleon did didn't but he gave me the
story you know I was in my late 40s and
uh he worked downtown San Francisco and
I just found that those lunches were too
big and I felt I was getting fat and so
you know instead of eating these big
lunches I decided to walk at lunch so he
started walking at lunch in his in his
late 40s and then um and then I asked
Napoleon about well I don't know we kind
of got into this question of what did
you eat for lunch he says well I don't
smoke I don't drink I always have had a
lot of um fruits and vegetables I would
always have fruits and vegetables when I
was working which I thought was really
pretty amazing you know 78 years old
they kind of got it a lot of this is
common sense they got it early on but
there's some other things to tell you
about Alan Napoleon Napoleon's been
married 56 years Al's been married 47
years and I would also say that there's
a social interaction on these walks
let's call it the great debates it
happened that this is where they debate
social social issues political issues
when they're out on the walk and also
some things that Al was in management
and Napoleon was in the union so they
get into these things but they always
but they have a smile on your fa their
face you know it's just this interaction
mental interaction and that's a
wonderful thing when you can combine the
physical exercise the mental exercise
the social put it all together um so now
the next person I want to talk to you
about is Ed now Ed had got his uh
actually Ed's in the audience Ed got his
uh master's degree in applied uh applied
mechanics applied mechanics here at
Stanford but then kind of fell into
teaching didn't want to work in the
weapons industry fell into teaching at
Ravenswood with which led to a 30-year
career as a teacher primarily a high
school teacher in math and this is Ed
actually just a couple of weeks ago
because every year for like the last 15
years he and a group of guys go on this
hike in the sieras and they hike in
about 15 you know 12 to 15 miles in and
back they're out there for about 8 days
so eight eight days that's probably
about a seven miles a day of hiking and
this is how Ed breaks wood for the fire
so he just gets the biggest B you know a
boulder and then he just throws it on
the wood this is how Ed breaks wood for
a fire and then afterwards afterwards Ed
does some yoga now sorry it's a little
out but then he'll do some yoga out in
you know after he's done these Seven
Mile hikes and whatever then he does
yoga out here now the other thing I have
to tell you about Ed you can't really
tell from these pictures but Ed just
have his 69th birthday last week and now
you might say that you know Ed had maybe
some genetics in here N I don't think
it's genetics but I would say it's role
models and I would say there's an
education Factor here but I don't I
don't know if you've heard of the
Delaney sisters who've written lived to
over um Bessie um Sadi sitting down she
passed at 109 Bessie's leaning over her
Bessie passed at 104 it happens that
Ed's mother was their younger
sister so um but I think that's that
role models that's one I why I want you
to think of the role models in your
family I don't I think it's not so much
genetics as it was Role Model in his
family and so what Bessie and Sadie
would say is here's what they say about
ex we get up with the sun and the first
thing we do is exercise God gave you
only one body so you'd better be nice to
it and for the last 35 years of their
life so if you're 105 minus 35 you know
70 they've been they were doing yoga and
I I couldn't find a picture of it but in
their book you can actually see them
doing these yoga stances so so that must
have come maybe that's what came through
Again by seeing them and actually when
um Bessie is going to be there ready for
ready for Ed in heaven and they're going
to dance together at those Pearly
Gates
um so next one how will you paint your
canvas this gets to kind of using your
mind a future awaits you at any
age be creative and learn new things
discover the Wonder with passion because
this is hope this is hope for the future
there is a future a future awaits you at
any age my best example I can give you
for this is Lithia now you would think
this was lithia's birthday party don't
this look kind of like somebody gave her
flowers for her birthday and my friend
Randy is her niece and this is Larry her
ry's husband um but actually and in this
this picture Lithia is 92 years old but
this actually wasn't her birthday this
was actually her graduation last year
from college she graduated with a degree
in English literature and a minor in
music and she lives back east and the
biggest turmoil in her mind was the
school that she wanted to go the the
school where she got her undergraduate
degree didn't have the master's degree
that she wanted so if she wanted to get
her master's degree she'd have to go
across to Across the Hudson River and
she was trying to figure out a bus
schedule
so education at any age leads to
successful aging so um okay last you
know it's not ultimately about you but
it is to start you really have to be
your own best friend because if you
don't value yourself enough you're not
going to do these things that are best
for you you know this is what gets you
past the denial you value yourself
enough but but then it's not all about
you you have to let go of self and you
transcend into a greater purpose of life
and this is that Civic engagement this
is the the giving back in the world um
and you want to pass on to the next to
the Next Generation this is the
generativity that you know as we become
older we're passing on to that next
gener the next generation and getting
Beyond getting Beyond ourselves up
maso's hierarchy of needs um actually
wait a minute I want to I want to end
with a story on Ed that doesn't have a
picture but um Ed got into meditation uh
some 80 80 30 years ago and he said it
really it really changed his it really
changed his life and when you interact
with Ed Ed is totally present to you and
there's a calmness and a peacefulness
that you that you sense when you're with
him but he is totally he is totally
present so the way Ed gives back now he
has four four grandchildren I I think
it's four four grandchildren and um he
told me the one story where where he and
totally present as one little
granddaughter opened his eyes one
morning Grandpa are you
up totally present and very calm to that
um but more importantly um Ed has been
on 30-day sits 45 days sits several
30-day sits 45 days sits in the silence
um he just came back from Dodson uh
prison in Alabama where for the third
time he has uh done a class with
prisoners to teach meditation so he just
came back from 10 days in the silence uh
with prisoners in Alabama so so that's
another way of getting Beyond yourself
and giving back so the message is the
choices you make will indeed determine
the life that you live and a joy filled
life really is your choice and it can be
there for you uh so in closing I would
like to um I'd like to say may your life
be filled with no regrets may you see
the extraordinary in the ordinary and
may someone be there to brighten your
world as you
age thank
you
now I see we do have a little time for
any questions if there are any I'd be
happy to um answer them or there is a
luncheon that awaits you outside and
time to interact with
people what do you think about caloric
restriction excuse meic
restriction actually that has been shown
in mice that's another way where they do
feel that that has an ability to extend
life but um as Tom spoke earlier today
there's not a feeling you know there
there is a feeling that there's there's
a life expectancy you know we're not
here to push human life to 200 years but
um definitely caloric restriction which
also falls in line with these um you
know keep your weight under control
don't be obese and it's it's it's
pushing it further so yes caloric
restrictions would also be um a more
refined one just as people who have a
real lowfat diet would be a more you
know
yes they did well that's
wonderful support your tro support your
troops that's another way getting
involved getting
involved
yeah the question was the question
actually the question was what about
introverts um you know actually this
this idea of being independent in our
culture you know we're going to be
independent and we're going to do it
this is kind of the cultural norm of
being independent and to the point of
being that is not that is not best for
you for when you're aging so someone who
is an introvert I would say step by step
try to get out to more people and I
would recommend that you you know maybe
you do it more oneon-one that you look
at it in terms of those more meaningful
relationships on one onone rather than
think that you need to make the friends
of you know a thousands that's what I
would say for somebody's who is an
introvert but I would say it is not a
successful aging strategy
yeah you know actually that's a good
point um you see it frequently as um as
as an elder care adviser you certainly
see it frequently um with older people
um having a companion and yes the love
and affection for an animal can really
be very supportive to an individual
very true but I would not I wouldn't
replace people for the animal I would
supplement people with animals in your
life
yes blanket
could well you know what I'd be happy to
talk to you sure the qu okay the
question it was a question on hoarding
but that's actually an elder care
question which I'm happy to um discuss
afterwards but I was going to stick on
um aging successful aging today for
questions hello es you talked about um
the importance of forgiveness forgive it
um forgiving yourself for um no it's
forgiving others about them not being
the parents you want or whatever what
about the importance of asking for
forgiveness of other
people as far as releasing a burden from
you say it again asking other people to
for to forgive you for maybe maybe
you've decided you haven't been the best
daughter you could be or the best sister
you know you can't you can't you can't
um modify other people's behavior so I
think the fact of you forgiving yourself
s that really becomes key it would be
great if you could but you can't depend
then it then you're pushing it out to
somebody else to finding you so the real
key is to get the Forgiveness within
yourself regardless of what that other
person might
feel one more question one more
question or lose it concept I I agree
with it exercise you know if I had to
give anything the the key for this
health mental mental and physical health
is exercise the key for emotional
well-being is social support social
interaction so Lo use it or lose it
absolutely inactivity yes yeah go for
it I'm class secretary for the class of
79 and I'm subbing for Randy Livingston
who had a lead I want you all to thank
Esther for this
oh
oh and and behalf of our class of 1979
who is honored to to bask in the
reflective Glory of of Esther we have a
gift for her oh how nice you all thank
you thank you so much
swe